et finissent au chômage la fin de leur
carrière donc tout ça il faut regarder
la pénibilité bien évidemment c'est un
sujet aussi donc il faut un vrai débat
démocratique là je crains que ça finisse
par un 49-3 c'est ce qu'on sent
c'est ce qu'on sent en toute façon le
président a décidé donc derrière il va
falloir que que tout le monde a décidé
de reporter la présentation pour laisser
plus de temps à la concertation ça c'est
un bon signal pendant je crois que c'est
pour laisser plus de temps à sa première
ministre surtout parce que ça coincé de
ce côté de ce côté là mais on a besoin
d'un grand débat sur le travail quelle
est la place du travail de notre société
revenir aussi sur les 35 heures moi je
pense que c'est une nécessité c'est
quand même très surprenant que le
gouvernement nous dise qu'il faut de la
sobriété qu'il faut consommer moins et
qu'il faut travailler plus en toute
logique s'il faut de la sobriété faut
être travaillé moins aussi donc tout ça
doit être posé sur la table dans ce
projet là on parle beaucoup du report de
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ou 65 ans
selon la volonté du gouvernement mais il
y a aussi des des mesures sur les
carrières longues voire très longs comme
l'a dit Olivier du sople sur l'emploi
des seniors sur les minimum retraites il
y a rien de bon pour vous dans ce
texte moi je l'ai pas vu le texte on
l'attend encore on attend encore mais
encore une fois je pense que ça aurait
été très utile qui a un grand débat et
qu'on commence par le Parlement
c'est-à-dire vous pour vous ça sera net
il y a pas de compromis possibles sur ce
texte si l'objectif c'est de finir sur
un chiffre 64 65 ou 62 ça absolument
aucun intérêt à côté peu importe les
mesures à côté de quelle manière vous
pouvez vous y opposer vous comptez vous
y opposés avec tous les moyens que donne
le Parlement et je pense que ça on sait
faire aussi alors pas dans la
multiplication des amendements ou c'est
là on pratique pas ce jeu là
non non c'est pas faire mais je crois
que c'est important c'est que les
oppositions justement permettent qui est
au Parlement un débat que aujourd'hui le
gouvernement nous refuse c'est ça le
vrai travail de l'opposition la
pédagogie montrer que la réforme n'est
pas inéluctable contrairement à ce qu'on
nous dit on peut parfaitement arriver à
une stabilité de tout le processus de
financement des retraites par d'autres
voix
le sens insoumise appelle à une marche
le 21 janvier pour protester contre
cette réforme est-ce que vous y
participerez moi je préfère quand c'est
les syndicats qui appellent à une marche
parce que je suis très très attentif à
respecter le champ syndical et le champ
politique il faut pas les confondre ça
veut dire que la France insoumise sort
de son rôle oui je pense parce que ceux
qui défendent les salariés c'est d'abord
les syndicats ce qui empêche pas les
partis politiques de soutenir les
syndicats les salariés mais sur une
réforme des retraites ceux qui sont la
manœuvre ce sont d'abord les syndics
pour voir un parti politique et la
France insoumise en l'occurrence n'a pas
appelé à une marche dans la rue je pense
que ça serait pas bon pour la démocratie
française que un parti politique alors
c'est pas un parti politique ça
rassemblement vous avez compris parce
que c'est gazeux c'est pas une bonne
chose
ben non c'est ce que j'ai entendu
il y a pas de vote parce que c'est un
mouvement parce que c'est gazeux je
pense que c'est pas sain que un
rassemblement accapare la totalité du
chant du champ politique mais aussi du
champ syndical on a besoin de tous les
corps intermédiaires et aujourd'hui on
se plaint que les syndicats sont mis de
côté donc il faut pas que les partis
politiques de gauche mettent les
syndicats sur le côté il y a des
tensions aujourd'hui entre la France
insoumise et le Parti communiste ça
discute ça discute on n'a pas les mêmes
idées partout on n'a pas la même
pratique partout parce que nous on est
rentré dans notre congrès et on va voter
parfois
certains de mes camarades trouvent qu'on
vote trop donc on a pas du tout en
pratique mais c'est à eux dont décidé
mais je j'ai du mal à comprendre comment
on peut défendre la Sixième République
et ne pas commencer à mettre en place
une démocratie exemplaire chez soi
comment on peut être
un peu autoritaire dans la façon de
gérer son parti et le lendemain si on
est au pouvoir un grand démocrate ça
c'est pas possible et par rapport et par
rapport aux parties on a une exigence
morale vis-à-vis des citoyens il faut
restaurer l'image des partis politiques
dans l'opinion française et ça ça passe
par une démocratie exemplaire à tous les
niveaux à la France insoumise il y a une
affaire qui divise et qui divise la
nuque c'est la faire 4 nains est-ce que
vous comprenez le choix de la France
insoumise de ne pas l'exclure
définitivement du groupe et de ne pas
l'appeler à démissionner et la joie à
lui de ne pas démissionner là aussi il y
a un fossé qui qui se creuse entre la
revendication très radicale et morale
que je soutiens de la France insoumise
sur la façon dont les politiques doivent
se comporter vous souvenez l'une des
positions fortes de la France insoumise
c'est le référendum révocatoire
la possibilité pour les citoyens qui ont
un lieu un député de lui retirer son
mandat donc il fallait jusqu'au bout il
faut organiser ce référendum révocatoire
dans la circonscription monsieur le 4
NAS et ça sera ensuite aux personnes qui
l'ont élu de savoir s'il doit continuer
ou pas
un programme c'est pas uniquement un
affichage il faut l'incarner il faut le
vivre donc là il faut que la France
insoumise elle soit en phase avec cette
propositions et y compris les plus
radicales on va parler de laïcité
puisque vous souhaitez
constitutionnaliser la loi de 1905 vous
allez nous dire pourquoi mais d'abord on
va faire le point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire quand un calmé
bonjour Quentin bonjour Yann bonjour
Pierre oiseau et Quentin quelle est
l'idée avec cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle de Pierre ouzouglia
alors l'objectif c'est de consolider la
loi de 1905 en lui donnant une place
dans le texte fondamental de la 5e
République la séparation de l'Église et
de l'État deviendrait alors un principe
constitutionnel tout en haut de
l'échelle de la valeur normative l'idée
simple voici l'article premier de la
Constitution on aime l'afficher ici sur
ce grand écran le lire ensemble la
France est une république est
indivisible laïque démocratique et
sociale elle assure l'égalité devant la
loi de tous les citoyens sans
distinction d'origine de Reims ou de
religion elle respecte toutes les
croyances son organisation est
décentralisée votre proposition de loi
consisterait à ajouter une phrase à cet
article premier la France ne reconnaît
nos salariés une subventionne aucun
culte ce sont ces mots qui sont ici qui
viendrai donc s'ajouter à l'article 1 de
la Constitution quelle serait la
conséquence d'une chaîne
constitutionnalisation on se dit qu'en
2022 117 ans après le vote de la loi de
la séparation de l'Église et de l'État
le principe est acquis qu'il est
impossible de revenir en arrière dans le
processus mais vous en fait l'idée c'est
plutôt de s'assurer que ce principe est
appliqué partout pierre ouzulia vous
avez expliqué dans une tribune au
magazine mariage qu'il fallait parvenir
à la séparation complète de l'Église et
de l'État et notamment en Guyane
Alsace-Lorraine ou avec le Concordat
elle ne s'applique pas aussi dans
certains territoires d'outre-mer dans le
texte vous écrivez le Conseil
constitutionnel neurait dès lors
d'autres choix que d'harmoniser le droit
en la matière provoquant un terme
l'abrogation des régimes dérogatoires à
la loi 1905 vous dites aussi que cela
permettrait de relancer un débat en
France sur l'importance de la laïcité
alors pourquoi exactement parce que
lorsque les parlementaires sont à
l'origine d'une proposition de loi de
modification de la Constitution les deux
chambres du Parlement se mettent
d'accord sur un texte puis il faut en
passer par un référendum et c'est donc
cette grande campagne référendaire que
vous dites qui pourrait y avoir un grand
débat sur la laïcité le principe de la
séparation de la séparation de l'église
et de l'étain c'est un acquis selon vous
ou est-ce qu'il est en danger
aujourd'hui mais d'abord alors je vous
remercie pour la sensation très
pédagogique de mon texte et ça fait un
plaisir ça fait un grand plaisir d'être
Public Sénat ce que moi vous faites
l'effort pédagogie pour les
téléspectateurs ensuite depuis
1905 il s'est passé plusieurs choses
d'abord la loi de 1905 n'a pas été
appliquée partout par exemple elle a pas
été appliquée à la Guyane il faut dire
parce que aujourd'hui beaucoup
l'ignorent que en Guyane la religion
catholique et religion d'État et
l'écureuils sont payés par la
collectivité unique pourquoi parce que
le gouvernement après 1905 a refusé
d'appliquer la loi de 1905 à la à la
Guyane après il y a bien évidemment
aussi l'exemple de l'Alsace Moselle mais
depuis 1905 il y a des dérogations qui
ont poussé comme des champignons partout
et qui fait que
et qui fait que le principe de laïcité
auquel les Français sont très attachés
ne s'appliquent pas sur tout le
territoire national alors comme vous le
dites la France est une République
indivisible individus un divisible ça
veut dire que la loi est surtout la
Constitution doit s'appliquer partout la
même façon donc l'objectif de ma
proposition c'est celui-là c'est
appliquer la loi et la laïcité partout
c'est effectivement ce que ce que vous
voulez dans le dans la proposition de
l'homme vous aimeriez aussi un
référendum sur le sujet ça c'est une
bonne opportunité selon vous il faut
débattre laïcité on en parle pas assez
c'est une valeur cardinale qui n'est pas
assez dans le débat public il faut
débattre pour expliquer ce qu'elle est
et surtout ce qu'elle n'est pas
j'entends de plus en plus souvent que la
laïcité ça serait repousser l'expression
religieuse les jeunes
ce serait une arme contre les les jeunes
musulmans par exemple mais la laïcité
c'est pas ça la laïcité c'est pas ça et
moi
Monseigneur Roger que vous allez
recevoir juste après moi vous le dire
vous le dira dans l'hémicycle au moment
de la loi sur l'air renforcement de la
République j'ai défendu les cultes alors
je suis athé parce que j'exprime je
pense que leur expression est nécessaire
dans le débat public
il contribue à la formation de la pensée
de la pensée politique et donc on doit
entendre les cultes mais pour ça il faut
que il y ait une neutralité totale et
absolue de l'État et c'est ce que je
vise par ce texte vous en avez parlé
avec les Alsaciens les Mosellans par
exemple ça risque pas de créer des
divisions alors ce qu'on sait pas aussi
c'est que depuis quelques temps il y a
une majorité d'Alsaciens qui souhaitent
laboration du Concordat pourquoi le
Concordat c'est Napoléon 1801 4 cultes
religion catholique deux culte
protestants et la religion juive
aujourd'hui ça ne correspond plus du
tout à la pratique religieuse de de
l'Alsace les musulmans sont écartés et
bon nombre d'églises protestante qui
sont non lutérielles et non calvinistes
sont écartés aussi donc ça ne correspond
plus à la pratique donc il faut échanger
ça sauf que le Conseil constitutionnel a
de façon Express interdit toute
modification du Concordat donc on arrive
dans une situation de blocage où il y a
pas d'autre chose que labrogation on a
vu parce que le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale les plus les chiffres
maintenant tous les mois que le nombre
d'atteintes à la laïcité avait augmenté
au mois d'octobre notamment avec des
jeunes femmes qui portent des vêtements
alors elle elle se défendent en disant
que c'est un vêtement culturel et non
pas culturel et des abats comment est-ce
que vous voyez aussi ce phénomène est-ce
que là vous vous dites aussi une dérive
d'une certaine jeunesse oui tout à fait
et je pense que le conflit entre
certaines formes d'expression de la
religion n'a pas cessé depuis 1905 c'est
à dire que la laïc non la laïcité c'est
un processus qui doit évoluer et surtout
qui doit être défendu en permanence dès
qu'on lâche un petit peu les choses
certains religieux reviennent parce que
pour eux la laïcité c'est un ennemi
c'est tout il y a une opposition
politique qui est forte et pour et pour
certains musulmans
minoritaires ils ne comprennent pas que
la loi de la République puisse être
supérieur à l'avoir religieuse ça c'est
des choses qu'il faut réaffirmer de
façon très forte
politique aussi et certains politiques
aussi tout à fait mais bien sûr
notamment du côté de la gauche de
l'extrême gauche même du gouvernement
même du gouvernement je pense que la loi
dite du renforcement de la République
n'allait pas dans le bon sens elle était
anti laïque sur ce qu'on est en période
de Noël il y a aussi des débats autour
de la question des crèches de Noël on a
notamment vu ces débats sur
l'opportunité de mettre des crèches dans
les mairies il y a aussi la crèche de
Noël de la ville d'illkrich
Graffenstaden dans le Bas-Rhin qui a été
incendié cette semaine elle était
installée sur la place principale tous
les sa pensée que l'incendie est
volontaire est le maire dit ce sont nos
valeurs et nos traditions qui sont
attaquées ce sont des traditions pour
vous ces crèches
oui mais mais non mais bien sûr et
encore une fois je suis athée mais
historien par ailleurs et je n'oublie
pas qu'elle a été l'importance du
christianisme dans l'évolution de la
civilisation occidentale je ne renie pas
ça les crèches dans les mairies ça c'est
pas possible puisque les services
publics doivent être neutres alors c'est
vrai pour les crèches mais c'est vrai
aussi pour les burkinis dans les
piscines de Grenoble rigoureusement pour
la même raison le service public Noël
neutre les crèches à l'extérieur quand
c'est dans l'espace privé ça me choque
absolument pas
la place d'une commune
la faut discuter là faut discuter il
faut discuter si c'est la mairie qui
elle-même met en place une crèche je
pense que il y a une rupture par rapport
au principe de neutralité religieuse
tout à fait alors là on est en Alsace
Moselle donc encore une fois c'est un
peu particulier
votre position
j'espère qu'elle sera examinée dans la
niche de mon groupe plutôt au printemps
et une demi-journée
même bon vous faites tout pour c'est
notre dernière niche donc elle est
pleine elle a craqué la niche vous avez
signé vous avez vous avez signé cette
proposition là avec Fabien Roussel tout
à fait donc député qui pourrait utiliser
aussi de son côté la niche de
l'Assemblée notre ambition politique ou
Parti communiste avec Fabien Roussel
j'étais très heureux de signer avec lui
c'est de remettre la laïcité dans le
débat public voilà mais dans un débat
rationnel et qu'il soit conforme au
droit ce qui est pas toujours le cas on
essaie de le faire ce matin c'était
parfait
une deuxième chronique parfaite ce sera
tout à l'heure pour un club parfait on
l'espère tout à fait on va faire un
petit rétrospective de ces derniers mois
parce que c'est notre dernière émission
aujourd'hui exactement merci Quentin à
tout à l'heure un mot sur l'autre
actualité du Sénat enfin une des autres
actualités du Sénat qui concerne les
communistes ça concerne la pénurie de
médicaments notamment et l'amoxicilline
et le paracétamol les communistes vont
lancer une commission d'enquête tout à
fait avec les objectifs comprendre ce
qui s'est passé parce que en ce moment
je trouve qu'on collectionne les
pénuries quand même
pénurie d'électricité pénurie de
médicaments pénurie de transport c'est
ce que je vis tous les matins donc il
faut qu'on comprenne comment on en
arrivait là voilà derrière il y a une
réflexion forte sur le rôle de l'État et
sur les médicaments tout le monde dit
que l'État n'a pas joué son rôle c'est à
dire que il y a pu d'organisation par
l'état de de la fabrication des des
médicaments avec une formule un peu de
corrigée
qu'on a du mal à corriger on a du mal à
corriger parce que la programmation
c'est ce qui vous permet justement de
prévoir des des événements extrêmes en
une formule ce que ce que démonte toutes
ces pénuries c'est que McKinsey va pas
remplacer l'État et on a besoin de
nouveau que toute la puissance
publique soit réaffirmée dans ce rôle de
régulation d'anticipation c'est plus le
cas vous savez déjà de quelle manière
vous allez travailler sur cette
commission
qui va s'en occuper il connaît très très
bien le sujet elle était intervenue à
plusieurs reprises dans le débat
notamment sur l'ordre de l'épidémie de
covid pour montrer que la France pays de
pasteur n'avait pas réussi quand même à
développer un vaccin ce qui est ce qui
est quand même terrible donc il faut
mettre tout ça là on va voir la qualité
de notre région
on retrouve geoffroyé bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos rédacteurs en
chef au Berry républicain et Geoffroy on
va parler foot avec vous puisque du côté
de Bourges dans toute la France on
retient notre souffle à deux jours de la
finale tant attendu de la Coupe du Monde
qui opposera donc la France et
l'Argentine
oui bonjour oui on se prépare dans le
Cher dans le Cher comme ailleurs il y a
eu un gros engouement pour la
demi-finale les barres qui diffusaient
le match était plein à Bourges à Vierzon
Saint-Amand-Montrond Aubigny-sur-Nère il
y a eu du monde dans la rue et des coups
de klaxons malgré le froid et la bruine
dès la fin du match notamment près de la
mairie de Bourges vous savez plus de 20
millions de téléspectateurs étaient
devant le match sur TF1 c'est la
meilleure audience de la chaîne depuis
2006 on peut dire qu'il n'y a donc pas
eu de boycott de cette Coupe du Monde
cela d'ailleurs été la position du de
notre journal le béret républicain dans
notre groupe de presse Centre France
comme la quasi-totalité de la presse
française pas de boycott de la
compétition mais outre des articles sur
le football nous avons publié plusieurs
articles sur des questions géopolitiques
environnementales et éthique posée par
l'attribution du Mondial au Qatar donc
monsieur uzudias que pensez-vous de ce
nombre et cote de la Coupe du monde
alors plusieurs choses d'abord je vais
pas tricher moi mon ballon préféré il
est il est ovale ce que je suis
originaire du sud-ouest comme votre
accent à mon avis ensuite je trouve ce
qui est ce qui peut être merveilleux
dans le dans le sport c'est
le rassemblement de tous les peuples
tous les peuples dans un événement qui
est planétaire se retrouve et voir
supporter français et supporters de
l'équipe marocaine unis dans la liesse
je trouve que c'est une magnifique image
pour montrer que nous sommes tout humain
tous des humains et qu'on parle et qu'on
peut participer dans la paix et l'amitié
à des événements comme ça après sur sur
le boycott là aussi il faut pas être il
faut pas être angélique le
Qatar a utilisé la Coupe du monde pour
son intérêt politique c'est parfaitement
admis
boycotter ça pas de sens ce qu'il faut
c'est c'est trouver le moyen de de
réformer un peu le mode d'attribution de
ces grandes manifestations pour éviter
justement que il y ait des problèmes les
morts pendant la construction des stades
des interdictions de certains
spectateurs liés à la façon dont le
Qatar a une une législation religieuse
qui est pas tout à fait conforme à ce
qu'on pense nous de l'amitié entre les
peuples donc voilà mais boycotter ça pas
de sens ce qu'il faut c'est une réforme
des des conditions d'attribution de ces
grands événements sportifs Emmanuel
Macron sera au Qatar dimanche comme il a
été lors de la demi-finale vous
comprenez qu'il aille supportait les
Bleus oui je pense qu'il y va aussi pour
autre chose si ils pouvaient trouver
quelques contrats gaziers pour les Verts
ça serait pas mal aussi je prends je
pense qu'il y va aussi avec ça voilà on
sait très bien que
dans les tribunes d'un stade d'un
président de la République qui peut
discuter deux choses que de football
voilà il doit passer un message
politique pour vous
non encore une fois je pense que
une fois que la manifestation est lancée
il faut pas cracher dans la soupe ça
c'est incompréhensible ce qu'il faut
c'est des garanties avant après là il y
a une allégresse les gens sont contents
de se retrouver ensemble il faut
respecter cette joie là
c'était juste pour vous dire qu'on se
mettait un peu comme tout le monde en
mode finale là avec voilà quatre pages à
venir des nombreux articles sur le web
dimanche juste pour vous dire on a un
interrogé à l'international français de
gymnastique qui est de Bourges qui est
face à un dilemme puisque c'est un grand
fan de Lionel Messi et on a vu aussi un
verrouiller passionné de football
argentin qui a choisi son camp ce sera
l'Argentine et il nous a glissé en
souriant qu'il n'y avait pas
d'injonctions constitutionnelle à
supporter l'équipe de France quand il a
raison il a raison merci Geoffroy merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on
regarde la une du Berry Républicain
c'est un papa noël à la plage ou pas je
sais pas où il est le papa Noël mais 10
idées pour profiter des vacances de Noël
très belle photo elle a une du très
belle image elle a une du du Berry
Républicain ça donne envie d'être en
vacances ça donne envie d'être à Noël
merci beaucoup Geoffroy d'avoir été avec
nous l'actualité dans votre région dans
la région Île-de-France pierre bouzulia
c'est moins réjouissant que la du Père
Noël on va notamment parler de l'état
des lycées des images d'un lycée
d'Aulnay-sous-Bois on fait évidemment
réagir on a vu un des fenêtres cassées
du chauffage défaillant des élèves en
doudoune qui était dans des salles à 14
degrés Valérie Pécresse a annoncé que
les travaux de chauffage seraient
effectués pendant les vacances de Noël
et qui aurait également des réparations
en urgence à la bien réagi
vous oubliez un événement qui est
important c'est que la région
Île-de-France a changé le son son mode
de financement des lycées pour réaliser
une économie de 18 millions de francs
alors je comprends il y a des problèmes
énergétiques des problèmes de chauffage
mais est-ce que c'est vraiment le moment
de diminuer le budget de fonctionnement
des lycées et comme d'habitude c'est
plutôt sur les lycées des communes
populaires que ça tombe ça fait mal bien
sûr il y a des difficultés
pourquoi parce que on revient à la
constitution la Constitution ce qu'elle
exige c'est l'égalité des droits c'est à
dire qu'il faut donner plus là où il y a
moins donc si on fait une règle
extrêmement neutre ou ondaine on donne
la même quantité d'argent dans les dans
les lycées des communes riches et des
communes populaires on crée un
déséquilibre donc la seule façon c'est
de donner plus là où il y a besoin parce
que c'est nécessaire de remettre un
niveau ce qu'elle fait pas donc on a
investit depuis que Valérie Pécresse est
à la tête de la région qu'elle investit
pour le plus d'un demi milliards dans
les bâtiments de l'Île-de-France et bien
sûr mais sauf qu'il y a eu des efforts
mais il y a un retard qui est
considérable dans les Hauts-de-Seine
c'est pareil il y a sans College il faut
un plan énorme pour les remettre à
niveau et leur permettre de justement de
faire face à ces problèmes énergétiques
est-ce qu'elle doit aussi rattraper ce
qui n'a pas été fait dans la mandature
précédente socialiste c'est évident et
je pense que les collectivités quelle
qu'elle soit ne peuvent pas le faire
sans l'aide de l'État c'est impossible
qui n'est pas suffisant non seulement
les pas suffisante mais on a bien
compris que l'État voulait diminuer les
dotations des collectivités donc on
arrive à quelque chose qui est une
appaui c'est une impossibilité merci
bien d'avoir été avec nous on vous
souhaite de belles fesses à vous aussi
on vous retrouve à la rentrée évidemment
dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires
toujours de Noël on ira voir le marché
de Noël de la ville de Colmar voilà un
peu d'illumination même s'il fait très
froid là-bas vous allez voir que le
marché de Noël quand même évidemment il
y a beaucoup de monde merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous vous allez laisser
votre place à quelqu'un que vous
connaissez c'est Monsieur rouget qui va
nous rejoindre c'est un ami